why doesn't the US have more walkable
cities one reason no one talks about is
US parking minimums that's basically
when developers are required to build a
certain amount of parking lots based on
arbitrary things like the number of
hospital beds residents or housing units
for example only 45% of households in
New York own a car but on average for
every hundred new housing units built in
the city 43 off Street spaces are
created the imposition of parking
requirements dates back to the 1950s it
was initially intended to ease the
demand for on street parking but these
requirements essentially compel each
resident to utilize more land this
contributes to an unnecessary increase
in the cost of every new housing or
commercial project not to mention an
overabundance of lots and garages if you
want more walkable cities it's time to
get rid of these local government
parking minimum laws